in an effort to strengthen consumer  protection Parliament votes on tackling  dual standards and products across  member states companies infringing the  rules that could face a stricter  sanctions members vote on a plan to make  key products and services in the EU more  accessible to people with disabilities  ticket machines computers and ATMs  should be made easier to use a trade  agreement with Singapore would remove  tariffs on over 80% of all imports  members vote on the deal which would  also liberalize a wide range of service  sectors new rules on motor insurance  would guarantee full compensation to  victims of driving accidents even if  their insurer is insolvent the EU wants  to reduce the number of people who drive  uninsured members vote on proposals to  increase the reuse of water for  irrigation the measures help to  alleviate water scarcity while  protecting health and the environment  [Music]